Is that actually a young Harrison Ford
in the "Indiana Jones and the Dial of
Destiny" trailer? No, but it's what the
filmmakers want you to think. While the
effects may not be fooling viewers just
yet, it does seem to be wowing them.
Disney and Lucasfilm have finally unveiled the
first long-awaited trailer for "Indiana Jones
5" — now officially titled "Indiana Jones and the
Dial of Destiny." This brief glimpse of the film
carries an impressive amount of emotional weight
and narrative reverence, leaning into the film's
bittersweet promise of a final send-off
for one of cinema's most iconic heroes.
"Those days have come and gone."
"Perhaps. Perhaps not."
While viewers found plenty to go over in terms
of references to previous entries in the series,
some fans were quick to focus on the first
look at the movie's de-aging technology.
Previous reports had confirmed that the new film's
major flashback scenes would de-age Harrison Ford,
but now fans have actually seen the footage,
and they can't stop talking about it. Normally,
it's an ominous sign when viewers have strong
opinions about anything CGI-related. Take,
for example, "She-Hulk." But in this case, the
response seems to be surprisingly positive.
Quite a few fans took to Twitter to marvel at how
well the de-aged shots of
the actor look. One wrote,
Another raved,
In an interview with Empire, Ford called the
de-aging technology "spooky" because of how
well it recreates his youthful looks. A fan
on Twitter pivoted off his comment, saying:
Even fans who admitted being
apprehensive about the movie
had to hand it to the effects. One wrote,
Another stated bluntly,
Yet another Twitter user grabbed a
still of Ford's de-aged face and wrote,
"Indiana Jones and the Dial
of Destiny" is, of course,
not the first time Disney has used technology
to digitally create a young version of an actor.
Recent entries in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
including "Captain Marvel" and "Black Widow,"
have used similar technology for scenes set in the
past. And a youthful version of Mark Hamill's Luke
Skywalker has appeared in "The Mandalorian"
and "Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker."
Some fans couldn't help but
compare previous uses of the
effects to what's in "Dial of Destiny." One wrote,
"It's not Samuel L. Jackson kind of de-aging
in Captain Marvel but it's still impressive."
"Thank you."
Viewers are certainly welcome to their
opinions of the best use of de-aging effects,
but the technology itself is clearly advancing.
Empire notes that the new "Indiana Jones" film
takes advantage of state-of-the-art
Industrial Light & Magic software,
which uses archival footage to accurately render
a more youthful version of a subject's face.
This technique is a far cry from
instances like the portrayal of
Luke in "The Book of Boba Fett," which
digitally superimposed a CGI version of
Hamill's face on a body double. Lucasfilm
President Kathleen Kennedy explained,